so as we continue our series on
omega-level mutant which focuses
explicitly on the powers of Marvel's
most powerful mutants in this week's
video we're going to be focusing on Hope
Summers now for those of you who are
unfamiliar with the terminology of
omega-level this phrasing is designed to
reference mutants who can work reality
are inherently immortal meaning they
can't be killed by any normal means or
have a level of telepathy telekinesis
which have reached a point where they
cannot be surpassed having said that if
you haven't seen my videos on the House
of M which you'll find in the
description this story came out of
editor-in-chief Joe Quesada desire to
reduce what he considered to be a
massively oversaturated population of
humans with the main story focusing
largely on Scarlet Witch kidnapping
Charles Xavier using his telepathic
abilities to read the minds of the
world's most prominent heroes and alter
reality to grant them their heart's
desire at the events conclusion The
Scarlet Witch had set reality back to
normal but utter the phrase no more
mutants while the idea going forward
after the House of M was a complete
elimination of the mutant population
because the core members of the x-men
including Cyclops and Emma Frost had
proven to be so popular instead of
eliminating the concept entirely Marvel
reduced the mutant population down to
198 covering the fallout of House of M
in multiple series including the
decimation storyline as well as the
limited series the 198 these story arcs
served to remove the mutants from the
landscape of Marvel Civil War storyline
but in 2007 Marvel began the process of
returning mutants to the landscape by
initiating the Messiah Complex event and
the birth of Hope Summers now enter
initial appearance the powers of Hope
were left largely ambiguous the reason
for this was that as a character who is
teased to be the possible reincarnation
of Jean Grey who had died at the
conclusion of Chuck Austin's run on new
x-men the first indication of hope
possessing incredible abilities came
when her birth triggered cerebro picking
up her signal and immediately
overwhelming Charles Xavier
due to the large energy she had put off
leading into a search between the x-men
William strikers purifiers who believed
it was a mission from God to kill
mutants as well as mr. Sinister's
Marauders over the course of these early
stories hope was shown to be the sole
survivor of a village Massacre in Alaska
where the powers of hope remained
intriguing and that the Messiah Complex
went on to establish that bishops
timeline
resulted in hope summers having wiped
out 1 million humans in the six-second
war leading to the launch of a signal
program and a world almost identical to
the Days of Future past now if you're
interested in learning more about
bishops future you can find this
information in its video which will be
in the description but the tie-in comic
new x-men number 46 established then not
only was host Sommers immune to the
touch of rogue but after making contact
with her she brought rogue out of the
coma that she had fallen into after
touching the hecka tomb a weapon of mass
destruction created by the Shiar empire
which housed the minds of 8 billion
individuals now regarding her name in
truth we don't know what hopes name was
following her birth however with cable
operating under the belief that hope was
destined to be a messiah who would save
both humanity and mutant kind Cable took
her into the future in an effort to keep
her safe and Bishop who looked to kill
hope and prevent his future from
happening now her hope would receive her
name due to cable marrying a woman of
the same name who went on to die in a
battle against the resistance group in
the future
not much emphasis was originally placed
on her abilities instead model focused
largely on developing hopes character
under the writing of Duane's was insky
having said that with Messiah Complex
serving as the first in a three-part
series parts two and three title Messiah
War and Second Coming offered expansions
on how being a potential house for the
Phoenix force what I mean here is that
with Messiah War seeing cable Deadpool
x-force and apocalypse coming together
and an effort to stop the villain strife
another omega-level mutant and the clone
of cable after taking possession of hope
strife claimed that she had the
potential to not only match his powers
of telepathy and telekinesis but exceed
them hinting at the idea that she was
both one of the most powerful telepaths
in the Marvel multiverse as well as
possessing a level of telekinesis that
would allow her to control the very
molecules of reality itself in addition
to this during the events of cable
volume 2 issue number 21 after Bishop
had caught up with cable and hope he
attempted to kill him by firing a bullet
which was stopped in midair by hope
after which she projected enough energy
to overload bishops ability to absorb
power and redirect it now something to
point out here is that in these early
years of her life helps powers were more
reactionary than anything else meaning
that she didn't have finite control over
them instead her emotions would take
over leaving her to react by dealing
with the threat of the time after which
her powers would
slide again however hopes ability to
control her powers began to develop and
expand even further during the events of
Second Coming and the third part of
Marvel's three-part series following
Messiah Complex and Messiah War and then
after returning to the present day
alongside cable the true abilities of
Hope began to manifest themselves with
the return of Hope Summers drew the
attention of some of the x-men's most
formidable enemies including Baal of our
Trask in Steven Lane two individuals who
were most prominent during the days of
the Sigma program as well as Bastion a
villain who had long since challenged
the x-men and originated as Nimrod the
perfect Sentinel from the Days of Future
Passed timeline during a battle
alongside Nightcrawler and rogue Hope
Summers took on a combination of
abilities including the waves of
Archangel the organic metal skin of
Colossus and the bone claws of Wolverine
now where this took most readers by
surprise and that the only indication of
host powers had been the potential to be
a telepath and telekinetic of the
highest order
writers craig Kyle Chris Yost Matt
Fraction Zeb Wells and Mike Carey and
all spent the next several issues
flushing this story out during the
respective tie-ins to the Second Coming
event taking place during the five
lights story arc at uncanny x-men issues
526 to 529 under Matt Fraction
where cerebro had detected five new
mutants who were the first five born
after Hope Summers Hope herself was
tasked with locating and offering the
mutants a place within the ranks of the
x-men team because this story was
designed to mirror the original x-men
comics in Charles Xavier
seeking out newly developed Newton's
offering his guidance and experience in
teaching them to use their powers after
bringing the mutants together and
forming a group called the five lights
and uncanny x-men issue number 541 Matt
Fraction used hoaxes previous displays
of power to explain that her potential
to be a telepath and telekinetic of the
highest order was not due to her
possessing telepathy and telekinesis
itself and instead was due to the fact
that she actually copied the abilities
of mutants around her and was able to
use them at their highest peaks
what this meant was that instead of
simply copying abilities and using them
the same way as rogue instead each time
hoped copy to mutant powers she was a
reflection of how powerful that mutant
could become if given enough time and
training the catch to this was that host
abilities to duplicate powers required
her to be within a certain proximity of
the mutant in question meaning she would
be unable to copy the organic metal skin
of Colossus if he were in America and
she were in Africa
however while different writers have
depicted this range in different ways
the end result was at at this point in
her history hope was defined as Omega
level and that she was unrivaled in her
telepathy and telekinesis and had
Cyclops optic glass Colossus organic
metal skin the ability to correct flaws
in the genes of mutants in addition to
the powers of super strength super speed
super Samana flight at faster than light
speeds teleportation energy projection
reality warping control over the
electromagnetic spectrum time travel and
a healing factor just to name a few in
essence if a power exists in Marvel
Comics and belongs to a mutant hope has
the ability to copy it and it's most
powerful form now regarding her
relationship to the Phoenix force while
she did play a big role in the events of
Avengers vs. x-men the early part of
this story dealt with the Phoenix force
returning to Earth to bond with hope
which resulted in the Avengers trying to
capture hope and the x-men attending to
protect her however in issue number 12
as the final part of the series it was
established that instead of hope being a
vessel for the Phoenix much like Jean
Grey hope was actually part of the
Phoenix force itself and went so far to
take on the position of the white
Phoenix of the crown now to expand on
this while the upper limits of the light
Phoenix have yet to be explored and
neither gene nor hope have used those
powers to their full potential in this
form hope was elevated from a mutant in
Marvel Comics to a multiversal cosmic
entity on par with the Living Tribunal
and well beyond the powers of Galactus
and eternity to this end as the white
phoenix of the crown hope has complete
control over all life in existence in
the multiverse and can end or create it
as well as create or destroy entire
universes now again most of our
information about the powers of the
white phoenix of the crown come from
jean grey but within marvel while there
is no information determining the
requirements on who can become a white
phoenix at a crown
aside from possessing enough psychic
energy to become a house without dying
it would stand to reason that these
abilities are universal meaning they're
the same regardless of who takes on that
position with that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end and
let me know what you think about Hope
Summers do you think that she's wildly
overpowered because if you don't then I
don't know what overpowered is what
would that being said I will catch you
guys later
peace